Welcome to the 100th episode of SmartLess, I am your new host Bradley Cooper, the other guys of They Resigned, they just asked for too much money. Nah, I'm just kidding, these guys are going to be right up. Here's a new episode of SmartLess. Sean, I just wanted to ask you about... Happy 100th episode, by the way. Oh, thank you. This is the 100th episode?
Congrats fellas. This is the 100th episode. Happy 100. Wait a minute. This is our 100th episode? This is our 100th episode. I think it's 100. That's crazy.
What is that? That's not... Isn't 50 as gold, right? What's the gold in that? 25 is... I guess there isn't a 100 anniversary because you'd be dead. 25 silver. Yeah, there's no 100.
There's no 100th anniversary. Who's married for 100? Well, it would be platinum. I think it would be platinum, wouldn't it? Well, I think 75th is diamond. Okay. 75th is diamond. Okay.
Let's look it up. Has anybody been married 100 years? Well, I know a couple who... It feels like 100. Oh, no. Is it you? What? No.
How dare you? No. It says... I googled it. It says, what is the 100th anniversary color? It's purple. Ideas is... You could do a photo spread.
You could do historical games. Wait, what site is that? Google. Google. Oh. It's not Google is not giving it to you. They've routed you to some other third party aftermarket site. Let's not get past the headline here, our own pathetic internal headline.
100. 100 means that we've done two years of shows, right? Can you believe that anybody would want to listen to us for 100? Let's take a second here and thank that single listener we have out there, Mr. or Mrs. Thank you for making it seem to yourself like listening to us three morons talk for an hour qualifies as entertainment, but please don't stop because we like doing it. Doesn't it feel like a week? It does feel like a week.
You sounded like... But doesn't it seem like... Like Jiminy Glick? No, it doesn't seem like Jiminy Glick. We've talked to 100 people. JB, did you play golf today under 100th? No, I just woke up late and I couldn't wash my hair. I've even gone to...
I'm on Amanda's computer. I don't have my glasses on. Walkers through. What's going on? If you could smell me right now. What are you going to cut the hair? Oh, my God. It's...
I kind of love in the hair these days. I got to say the other day, I really loved that it was coming out every side of your visor. I don't. I don't like it. And why do I listen to my wife about the length of my hair? Can't I just keep it short and dorky and dumb and square and... No, don't worry.
You look dumb and square a lot of the time. You're son of a... By the way, the thing about Jason is... I think everybody knows, Sean, you and everybody knows him knows that one truth actually doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. Well, what is it? It sounded like it might be a compliment.
So continue. No, it doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. No, I'm not going to get it. Because it's not fair. We all know this, but we're not going to say it to him and forget it. It doesn't matter. All right.
Three, two. Well, you are talking about... Fucking hook, line and sinker. There is no thing. That was a test, but I was going to say, Sean, I just want to say this. I want to tell a true story that happened the last couple of days, and this is Jason. And I love him so much. We're playing golf against these guys.
And if you understand golf, and if you're bored, go wash the dishes for a second or turn... Sean, not you. No, by the way, we're just trying to stay connected to the people, by the way. When we're out there playing golf, we're just trying to keep it... We're playing with randos. We're going out to the public course and we're just picking up a couple of randos and we're saying, come hit with us.
That's fine. That's fine. We're playing against these guys and they're crushing us on the front nine. They're beating us. I'm all over the place. I'm playing terrible. Jason's not playing. He's pretty great, but he's not playing as normal, great.
And so after nine holes, they're beating us. On the back nine, totally different. And you don't know these guys. We barely know. We sort of know one of the guys. We know one of the guys. The other guy, we don't know. On the back nine, we start to come back and there's one hole left and we're walking from
the 17th green to the 18th tee and we have a chance to eradicate the loss and Jason goes all we got to do. They're up ahead of us. I don't speak like a dude from Bayone when I want to get down to business. What we got to do is we got to get a nice piece of study. Get some sausage. No, he says all we got to do is we got to win this hole. He goes, I'm telling you, man, if we beat these guys, they should kill themselves.
What is this? The karate kid? And I go kill them. I go, take your foot off the gas, man. It's Wednesday, OK? They should kill themselves. I was trying. I had to get myself up.
He went so psycho, Sean. It was. I believe it. It was crazy. That's where my wars are fought, you know? You take it really seriously. Listen, we've come, we're at a hundred episodes. I just want to just say this because this is the last time we're going to sit because
the next time we record an episode, we're not going to be able to say this. In four days, it's Will and it's birthday. Speaking of a hundred, Will and it's birthday. Oh, it's a century, you're a century years old. Oh, happy birthday. Yeah, happy. Love you. Sweet, sweet, Willie.
Thank you. How old are you going to be? Let's go. I'm going to be 52. Don't make me Google it. I'm going to be 52. So we know that this is recorded before my birthday and very generously, our friend is having a nice birthday dinner for us tonight and the kids and everybody.
And I'm generously showing up. And I, too, am. And I'm so excited to see you guys. I know, I'm too. I haven't seen you guys in so long. I mean, no, because you were in Chicago and I've been in Atlanta. I've seen Jason, you know, when he suggested those guys kill themselves, but I'm really generally excited.
What do you hope to get for your birthday? Yeah. I mean, I know it doesn't really matter about gifts once you get past about 12. Oh, God. I don't even think about it. Are you looking for anything? No, I don't ever expect to get a gift. You think you're going to get anything from your boys?
I hope they get like a nice picture or like a poem or something. They're able. They're both really good. They're really nice that way. I'm going to be redundant because I wrote you. I wrote you a poem. Let me, honestly, what are the odds of them writing you a poem? I don't know.
I'm just really excited to, I don't know, just excited to see you guys and have all the people I love and around and, I don't know. Yeah. That'd be super fine. I'm going to write it tonight. That's going to be my goal is to get you to cry tonight, which might mean I might stand up and do a toast, which I can't, I hate doing it. I love it.
Nothing makes me more nervous than getting a toast. That's why you got to do it. That's why you got to do it. Is it true? Yeah. I could give me anything in front of the camera or whatever is fine, but making a toast or speech in front of a bunch of people on stage, when we did the tour, in front of an auditorium full of people on stage with a spotlight is the most nerve wracking thing.
But you were great. You were great. You couldn't tell. You were great. But, you know, I mean, I've got, I've got acting skills. I know how to bury the. You just don't like it. But I just don't like it, but especially not a toast.
I just feel like such a beach bag, expecting people to stop what you're doing and listen to me as I hold up a glass. It's the most arrogant thing I've ever done. Nothing I love more. Nothing I love more. No, but it's nice. It's nice. We're going to do it tonight.
We're all going to toast each other. It's going to be. I mean, my toast is going to be here's to Jason's toast and then I'm going to force you to. Oh, and pass it on. That's nice. Jason, you just, you just don't, it's tough for you to, to connect on that emotional level. And I think that if you just connect to the feeling and forget what you have to say, nobody's judging you and just connect to the feeling for once, you imagine what a breakthrough
that would be. Guess what? That's what you're going to get tonight. We're going to reference this tonight and then I'm going to stumble my way through it. I can't wait. Pick me up. I am not going to break eye contact with you either. I am not breaking eye contact.
No matter what, speaking of eye contact, our guest, an optimologist is someone, if you make eye contact, if you happen to get locked into this person's gaze, this is a hundredth episode guest. This is better. Let me say something. Well, this better be something that we've all locked. Better be good. This is somebody we've all locked gaze with real, not just us.
The world has locked the gaze and he is locked in on the world. He has made a connection, a contact that is tough to be broken. But this is something that we've been in contact with for a long time. The three of us are friends with this person. This person is a friend of the show. This person is a friend of ours. This person has seven more Academy Award nominations than the three of us, which means that he has seven.
I don't know anyone that has seven, Academy Award. Seven nominations. I know this person. Four for acting and three for directing and all of the above. This is a person that we all adore. This is a person who's been part of our lives for a long time that we've been on a journey with for a long time. He takes my hair.
He has single-handedly just absolutely done incredible things over the last 15 years, but he's always been an incredible person, but on top of it, he's just an incredible guy. I don't want to talk about his work accolades because I want to talk about how much we love this person. I can't wait to bring them in for our 100th episode I have brought our dear friend, Mr. Bradley Cooper. I've admired Will for so long, honestly, you're talking, I was getting so excited that you
were talking about me. What a nice bait and switch, though. I can't believe he's talking about me, he's actually saying these things about me. We used to be like, we used to share an apartment, the best was like, does he ever even think about me? I love you. Do you remember the apartment? You guys all remember the apartment.
I remember we used to play cards downstairs in that old apartment. What was the actor's name that lived below you? Ron Rifkin. Ron Rifkin. And his wife, Isla, lived in the front. Now, Bradley, you know, I thought this is, I would have never guessed because I thought we used all the favor you would give us by you making that cameo on the live version. I thought I used it up.
So when Will texted me, I was so excited because I thought that you guys had no more interests. People don't know that you joined us on the tour socially backstage, we were all hanging out for a long time. It was so fucking fun and you came on only briefly. So you haven't really done an episode, so this is great. But now we get a full 60 minutes, although we have cut into your time a little bit. We've cut it, yeah. We always cut into people's time with our garbage, which is...
No, that's the best part of the show. Let me start. Bradley, can I start? Bradley, what's your middle name? Oh. Oh, God. And then Sean's going to go color. I'm going to give a little history.
Can I give a little history? Can I give a little history? Yeah, go history. Bradley, you go. Because for everybody that knows the show, you know, I've had the great fortune to know all of these guys separately for about 20 years each. Yeah, that's crazy. And each one of their circles, they have always been the funniest person in the room and everybody
knows it. And I'll go as far as to say that Will's probably always been the king of every room combined. That's right. Literally what everybody's always said. It's just... You can't be Will. You've...
Everyone's playing for the silver. Yeah. So for all these guys to be together, and I said this on stage too, but I finally, like what I've been able to be a benefactor of, now everybody gets to as well. And that's part of why it's so successful. But the other thing was, like, you have this way of talking, Jason, and the first, like, I don't know, 15 years I knew you, I was always like, oh, he's fucking with me. What's your middle name, Bradley?
No, Bradley, what's your middle name? Like I give a fuck what your answer is. I'm just looking for a way to demolish you. So every time I'm like, oh, I don't know, Jason, it's Charlie, it's Charles Cooper based on my dad. Who died? Are you going to make fun of that? Well, you know, I do, I do, I do.
Are you going to hit me there, Jason? I do admit that I sound and act a lot shittier than I really am. Now, I'm not going to make this up without me. That is true. By the way, can I say that? So that was the first 15 years. Yeah. I'd say the last five years I've come to realize that Jason is a really kind of a wonderful
human being. Yeah. I'm not the ass who you thought I was. Or that everybody thinks I am. But there is something about the tone, the prosody one could say of the way you speak. I'm just... I'm... I see...
Will and I... You could get five amens. You can get a shit girl. Oh, shit. Will and I saw some time on the documentary behind the scene special that we shot of this tour thing. Yeah, Bradley. You know when Sam was shooting that thing, right?
Yeah, of course. Yeah. And so Will and I saw a couple hours of it and I said to Will yesterday, right before I said that golfers should kill themselves, that I said, I think I'm just such an asshole on that thing. Don't I seem like a real... He's like, no, man, me. I think I'm just a crabby...
By the way, and this is why you were like, Sean, why didn't you come? I didn't want to go through this. Like I don't want to like... Well, let me tell you something, son, Sean. You couldn't be sweeter. You couldn't be nicer. You look... You come off looking like...
When you're the prick... Yeah. You're the mother. Yeah. You're so... You're happy, go lucky. Hey, guys. I don't mind.
Turn the cameras off. First of all, the first 20 minutes... We talk about food. Oh, my God, it's hilarious. It's nothing but food. And what we kept in was, because Jason keeps bringing up, Bradley, you love this, Sam kept in was me finally going to Jason, you're going to watch this, and you're going to see how obsessed with food you are, and you're going to be so ashamed at your fucking neurosis.
Okay. It's so true, though. It's not true, but you're not an asshole. I'm an asshole. Because anytime anybody says anything, I just like hammer them. But wait a minute. I hope everybody knows that we all love each other, and that's why we can get after each other like brothers.
Of course. Bradley, you're obsessed with food. Bradley? Jason's not the only one. Oh, look who's here. It's Bradley. Right? Because you are...
Your body is insane. What? My body. Your body is insane. You're always in such fucking great shape, always. Not Sean. That is just incorrect. Oh, my God.
That is an incorrect statement. No, it's not. It's pretty close to true. I literally was just at the rehearsal today with all these dancers, because we're doing this part of the movie. I'm about to start a movie, so we're in prep. Bradley's playing Leonard Bernstein, and it's going to be great. I was watching the playback, and I was like, I look like a fucking lion, like a wrestler
with my shoulders. I was like, dude, what are we going to do? It's like, all these beautiful bodies, this is fucking me, like dancing like I got fucking like lead on my feet. But by the way, you are like, you know, I thought, you don't see somebody who's like super fucking talented, super fucking nice, super fucking handsome, and then you see them do another thing really well, and you're like, oh my God, life's not fair. Every time you dance on something, it's incredible.
Like I can't. I actually do love to dance. That was like the one thing bar mitzvahs, I couldn't wait for the bar mitzvah, that was all my time. For women to get women's attention. Wait till they get a load of me. I'm like getting number like, let's get Shabbat Shalom. Shabbat Shalom.
Shabbat Shalom. Good Yantuff. Good Yantuff. Good Yantuff. But I will say this. I mean, Bradley, dancing or whatever it is, when you did Star is Born, I had this like, Bradley and I had this surreal moment years ago. That was amazing.
Remember that? I was at Cinemacon. Cinemacon. And I got to introduce Bradley Cummins. He was showing a trailer for his movie, and he just directed this huge and written this and in this movie and produced, and we stood there on the stage with the whole audience and watched it. And it was so surreal.
We both had tears in our eyes. Yeah, we were both crying. It was great. And you had to host this whole thing, which was nuts, and you had this like, did you have a white suit on? Am I crazy? Or was like, it was like, you had like this like, like really, like this, like, really cool suit on, and you were sweating, like you were like, I mean, you were working your
ass off, dude. Yeah. Yeah. I was working my ass off. It was fucking crazy. It was like Elvis in Vegas. Like, literally, it felt like Vegas, because that Cinemacon stadium is very vertical. Remember?
Yeah. It's like, it's not, there's not much depth. It feels like you're in the Thunderdome. I looked like I had just eaten a million fry banana sandwiches, too. I looked so huge at the time. I was a dump. What? Tan is fucked, too.
I remember that. Was Leonard Bernstein dancing in this movie? No. Yeah. Yes. Well, I don't want to give it, but there is this sort of magical moment. But tell people, I don't know if you heard me, Bradley's right written, directed and starring again in a movie.
This time he's playing Leonard Bernstein, which is crazy. It's a movie about marriage. It's not a biopic, but yes, yeah, I do play Leonard Bernstein. Yeah. Yeah. We started shooting May 21st. We just, I just got back from Massachusetts yesterday. We drove there.
That's so exciting. I can't wait. You know, it's been four and a half years in the making, and I'm, I feel very grateful. I feel so grateful. This has been such a labor of love for you, man, and you have put in the work and you've gone through so many stages of shooting pieces and developing it and writing it and researching it and learning. And Jason was kind enough to sit through a lot of the test proofs that I showed you,
remember? And that was one of the times as I walked back in my car, I'm like, oh, he's just ripping me apart. No. Are you out of your mind? So you're trying to pretend that I was like giving him that? I would sit, I could sit there for 40 years and watch what you'd talk about. You know how I'd dork out on all that stuff, but I'm so like, you could have picked anything
to do, A, with your first film. You could have taken a much smaller bite. But no, the huge scope and the scale of that thing with a big, huge co-star and a remake of like a beloved, and now you're going to move into this epic about a beloved American icon and going into like make a press, a little bit of prosthetics, maybe or like, no, a lot. I mean, he's 25 to, to, to at least 69. It's just, you're not phoning this in.
I'm no different than all of you. I mean, Sean, Sean, you're just Oscar Levant. I mean, you've created this whole entire world, Jason and Will, you've forged your own path that no one could even like compare. So everybody's done what they love. Yeah. It's just the truth. I don't know if I could play below 30 anymore.
I don't even know. You need the prosthetics. Yeah. Probably to below 30. If I had to dip below 30, probably. I said to Bradley, because Bradley's playing Leonard Bernstein and he's gay, well, part of his life, he was gay. And I said, you're going to be making out with two, do you see what I'm saying?
Just the bottom part or? There's a... We're holding for laugh and rejoining. Which part? You waited. I said, I said, you're going to be making... You waited. He just like, bam.
I'm going to stay back here in the five yard line. I could see it. My man's going to get open. Okay. Okay. Part of it. Do you have to make out with dudes in the movie and everything? And he said, yeah.
And I go, look, I can run lines with you if you want. Was there nothing that was right for Sean in the film? I mean... Yeah. You know who's in the movie, Sean? Sean, you know who he is. Who's in the movie? Scott Ellis, huge part.
No way. You're joking. Yeah. Scott Ellis, the director of theater on the Broadway. No way. Yeah. He was perfect with this role. I asked him to do it.
He said, yes, we just closed the deal today. I'm so excited. That's so exciting. That's really exciting. That's great. That's cool. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
I was going to go back to something Jason said about choosing a star. I want to get... I thank you for talking about me, but I do just... I just feel like I want to educate the audience about you guys. So let me know what you've done. No, no, no. They're so sick and tired of us, Brad. I don't think...
I don't like this stuff about the kids and other stuff, but like... Guess what? I didn't want to click on this. Said, oh, Bradley. That's a Bradley episode. We want to listen to this. Okay. It's all about you right now.
Fucks. Bradley has nine nominations. I fucked up. Whoa. Academy award nominations? Yeah, nine, motherfucker. What, did you just finally click on Wikipedia? Yeah, I just...
So I was at this party. I was at this party. I mean, you know... I mean, I know Will's like this. You know, I never forget anything anybody mean has ever said, right? It's like cataloged. I can tell. I know exactly where I was.
What are you talking about? You know, I challenged the verbiage, the sentence structure. I'm like, no, bro. That's not what you said. I never forget. I was like... You know, the CAA party like four years ago, I don't remember. At that time, it was like seven nominations, which is crazy.
It's nuts. And everybody's like, huh? It's crazy. But this director guy, I'm standing next to a woman who's a dear friend who's an actress and he goes, how many do you have? And I was like, oh, yeah, I have seven. How many do you have? Three.
What world are we living in where you have seven nominations? What, she's only got three. What is wrong that you... And I remember I was like, I fucking hate this business. No way. Oh, I never forget it. I remember, I'm looking. I'm like, bro, why are you such an asshole?
I would never fucking forget that. Don't fuck yourself. I would make it a point to fucking crush that person. And then the first time I was nominated, I never forget this. I'm at that same party, this 2011, nominated with Daniel Day fucking Lewis, right? It was crazy. And Denzel Washington. I couldn't believe it, right?
I'm like levitating and this like hero, female actress that I didn't know at all comes up to me. She goes, I think, well, you know this story. She's like, I saw your movie. You deserve the nom. Woof. I was like, what? I'm sorry.
What? The nom. And then like 10, 20 minutes later, I'm not kidding. I passed her like going to the bathroom and she like, and she mouths it. The nom. Wait, why was she trying to keep you down? I mean, like, don't win. You're never going to win.
Why was she trying to keep you down? I don't know, dude. But I remember like, what the fuck is this town? Because people are fucked up, man, because it's all, most of the time when you encounter people, I would say like 80% of interactions have to do with them. It's got nothing to do with you. You know what? You know what?
You're 100% right. Well, anytime anybody says anything negative, it's about their self-hatred. But could you imagine saying that to somebody? I mean, like, I mean, no. You've got to be fucked up to do that. No? I mean, here's what I'm going to push, but here's what I'm going to push back, Jason. It's kind of what you were saying before about feeling like you're an asshole.
None of us in here would ever actually say something like that. I will bust some of these balls. Well, funny though, Sean, 2012, we were at... Oh, boy. Oh, no. Let's play the tape. Funny you should say that well. Thank you.
We were at Victor Garber's on Sunset Plaza. It was 8.30. We just had the tuna. I'm trying to go, this smells like your career. Although I will say, coming up in like 1999, 2000, and the comedians that were very popular back then, mean humor was the thing. And being an insecure person, I was like, and I knew because of Amy, I got to know Will and all that circle, and then doing wedding crashers got to know those good, right?
So just around and seeing like, oh, and I remember there was a good year where all I did was try to access mean humor only out of insecurity in hopes that people would think I'm funny. And I still remember doing this like TV show. It's so embarrassing and like really hurting people's feelings, only trying to mimic people that I thought were funny. And Will, do you remember this? And I'll never forget, man.
We were living next to each other and Will came into where I was living. And he's like, hey man, we had dinner the night before, I know you're not supposed to cry on this show, sorry. This is pretty emotional. I'm not crying. I'm not crying. You're crying. I'm not crying.
You're crying. No, but I'll never forget it because Will, who can be mean, but there's no ill Will. It's just like, if you know each other, you feel safe the way we do. But I didn't know Will that well then. And he was like, hey man, do you remember we had dinner the other night? And he goes, how'd you think that went? And I was like, and I remember being at the dinner thinking I was so funny. And I thought these two guys who were my heroes were so, thought that I was so funny.
I don't know if you remember this, Will, and you're like, I was like, oh, I thought it was great. I thought I was killing it. Hey man, you were, and Will, I'm not telling you, you were a real asshole, man. You were a real asshole. And I was like, what? He's like, yeah. And by the way, have your dogs gone out to the bathroom?
And I was like, what? What time is it? It's four o'clock. Oh no. I think they have to go to the bathroom. They're literally standing by the door. And that was like the first time I ever realized I had a problem with drugs and alcohol. And it was Will saying that to me.
And I'll just never forget it. And I was like, oh, the guy that I think is doing mean humor is telling me like truth about that. And it was like, it changed my entire life. And that moment was when I stopped pursuing this sort of mean humor thing. Wow. Because I heard, yeah, I'll never forget. Do you remember that, Will?
I do remember that, yeah. Wow. Wow. Thanks for sharing that, Bradley. That's amazing. And Bradley, was it because you were trying to quote, fit in and that's how you set this up? Yeah, of course.
I mean, zero self-esteem of trying, you know, zero and thinking like, oh, here's something like my brain works fast. Oh, I can be mean to people, right? If I'm like finding the holes and I can figure out. And then you realize that it's not mean. It's just a type of humor. It's a sense of comedy. Kind of like Don Rickles was the king of insults.
Well, actually, I would argue that like, I mean, it's tricky. That's a tricky conversation. But I didn't, I was so starving that it didn't matter that I was hurting people. I didn't even think that I was, because I didn't think I was powerful enough to hurt anybody anyway. So I never thought it was really hurting anybody because how could I if I'm worthless, right? So there was the sort of the pre of that, if you don't. So we had another friend and you and I had done not long before that we'd both weirdly
just randomly had to do a photo shoot at the same studio. Do you remember that? I forget what it was for, but anyway, and you were, there were a bunch of other people that were doing it in different stages in Hollywood, like on Formosa or something. And you were kind of going through that stage where you were just being very aggressive at that, and, you know, and you were funny, but you were also like sometimes like really hardcore and it was like, whoa, man. And I remember thinking, and then that night was kind of that moment when I was like, and
the truth was, I remember at that time being at that, at that stage and this buddy was there saying like, wow, I feel really bad, but he's been coming on really strong. And I go, I think that it's okay. I think he's just trying to fuck around and it's okay. And then that happened with our other friend. And I just remember thinking, that's always a tricky thing, but I just remember thinking, you know, I love you and wanted you to be okay, you know what I mean? And I knew that you weren't feeling great about stuff.
Was that the moment, Bradley, that you just described or was there something more, even more significant that made you, that clicked in your brain that says, oh, shit, I really have to look at myself and maybe take a left turn. Well, I was so, I mean, I was so lost. I was so lost. And I was, you had a weird, you had a, and I was addicted to cocaine, you know, that was the other thing. And you injured your, remember you injured your leg.
Oh yeah. I was seven Michaelis tendon right after I got fired slash quit alias. And that, you know, it was, it was, it was, you know, But you know, the people say, you know, success will show you who you are, you know, that will bring out, it'll surface who you are because what it triggers is usually a pretty permissive environment around you. So you know, you don't, you can drop whatever artifice you've been using here to for, right? So what's great about your incredible level of success is that it did the opposite of
what is kind of traditional and cliche in this business where, you know, the more famous and rich you are, the bigger prick you are, it allowed you to be as kind and vulnerable and human as you innately are with no fear of that being misinterpreted. I've talked about before about how Ron Howard is sort of this great North Star for me with that. Like he doesn't ever worry about anybody thinking that he's too eager to talk to them or too eager for a job when he walks into a room all smiles and chatty, you know, because he doesn't need it.
You are the same way. And it's allowed you to be what is universally agreed upon as far as your reputation goes, your attention to your coworkers, irrespective of the position that they hold on the set. It's just, I think it's an incredibly admirable thing and you can't hide from that any longer. But I will say this, you know, I did have the benefit of that happening when I was 29 and I definitely would not, I mean, I thought I was, I thought I made it when I got a Wendy's commercial and I called my dad saying, you know, I'm in a hotel that has a window that opens like and it's paying for it, you know, so I mean, I mean, in terms of the made it
thing, you know, that's when I made it. But I definitely did not feel moving to Los Angeles for alias feeling like I was back in high school, couldn't get in any clubs, like no girls want to really look at me. Like it was like, what? I mean, I totally depressed, you know, so, so at 29, it wasn't till really hangover. I was 36 when I did the hangover. So I got to go through all of those things before fame even played into my, my existence on a daily level.
So all that happened before any of that, which makes you so appreciative of where you are. Yeah. And then it's just like, that's like, oh, it is, it's an element has nothing to do with anything. And so that's what I was going to say, Jason, because Jason has made that point before, but I would, I agree with Bradley, Bradley, you actually went through this metamorphosis before hangover, like you said, before all this stuff and having those realizations and having that change allowed you, that's what opened you up and allowed you to be you and
allowed you to be. It's true. What? What? When you say that, what do you mean? Just going through all those things. I, again, you know, still working on self-esteem up until, you know, like a year ago and still do, but like, but I definitely made major breakthroughs, you know, 29 to 34, 2, 3, 34, where at least
I was able to like stand in front of somebody and breathe and listen and talk and, yeah. By touching bottom, was touching bottom one of the things that allowed you to kind of push off? Oh, I mean, that was the, of course, that's the game Scotty and I play. Touching bottoms. Yeah. I was going to say, Sean, touching bottoms for you. That was different than that.
That was different than that. Started as a board game. It probably was. I can't relate. I can't relate. Probably was. But the fact that Will, they call it your Eskimo, Will is the reason he took that risk of having that hard conversation with me in like July of 2004 that put me on a path of deciding
to change my life. And it is truly Will Arnett. He is the reason and there's nobody else. I'm not the reason. No. I'm the reason that I was like, oh, you know, and it helped that it was the guy that I thought I was emulating. Do you understand what I'm saying?
It's not like somebody else said it like the king told me and that's that that was the thing that was so crazy. I'm like, wait, the king came down to tell you the, what you're doing is not what you really should be doing or what's right or who you even are. I was just going to ask the simple question of how did you learn esteem then? How did you get it back or discover it? Was there a specific moment or was it a gradual? You know, increase of events that led you to go, okay, I can, it's okay to like myself.
It's not a selfish thing to like myself and all of those kinds of things. I mean, I don't know about all of you, but it's a lifelong exploration. I definitely felt like it occurs and has occurred in increments. It started out about my relationships to men. I think I would always idolize male figures and then have them fall off the pedestal because they were, I created something that wasn't even, you know, one couldn't live up to. And in one's art, I think that was sort of the second thing to be okay to be feel comfortable in the things I want to create and having a voice and then just intimacy, the hardest
intimacy. Yeah. And quite honestly, it hasn't been until about a year and a half ago that I decided like, I'm just at sea and I love so much of my life, but I'm so lost. And it wasn't to, you know, working with a new therapist and quite honestly, like today I can sit in front of you saying, I actually do have self-esteem that's not related to any outside thing. And I didn't have that for 46 years.
So it's taken me quite a long time to do that. Can I just say, Bradley, there is such a difference. You know, we got, we had the benefit over the last couple of months, we were in New York and stuff and hanging out for the, the most we've hung out in a number of years. Yeah. I, it has been awesome seeing you in this place and seeing you comfortable. Nothing has made me happier. Just even hanging out at the house with Leah and just seeing you be you and making food.
And I honest to God, dude, I was like, now I'm going to cry. It's made me happy to see you so happy with who you are. And you and I talked last year, I called you, do you remember this and I said, I had a moment last year where I was like, I was so fucked up about like who I was and relationships and all this stuff. And I had this moment. I told Bradley, I woke up and I went to make coffee and I went, holy shit, it's me. It's not everybody else.
It's me. And that moment I talked to Bradley and Bradley was like, yes, he was in the same spot. We talked about it. We talked about this guy and he turned me on to this thing and it was been unbelievable. Anyway, I'm really happy for you, man. Jesus Christ. You guys are awesome. I mean, is can you-
I've loved myself since the time I got out of the womb. I got shot out loving the shit out of myself. You're like, I cannot relate to any of this. Nobody can believe that you love yourself. How could you possibly love yourself? Can you guys attribute any of this kind of new found peace and centeredness and all that stuff to- is there a correlation to having your children and trying to provide them some guidance early on that perhaps you may have missed or didn't see come in?
Is that- I'm sure it's all part of it and it wouldn't be just the only thing. But I know you're both incredible dads, so that's why I ask. I mean, fatherhood is- I mean, everything changed. So the answer is absolutely yes, along with like, you know, how I drink water. I mean, it's like, you know, every single thing is absolutely shaded by or brought out in glorious colors by the fact that I get to be a father to a wonderful human being. I mean, it's just the absolute greatest thing. And I think it really- in regards to the work we do, I was literally talking about this
a couple of days ago and thinking about, you know, you have this wonderful thing or a breakthrough with the script, right? Or you're like, oh my gosh, this person and you have a wonderful moment on a set or wonderful moment in the editing room, you have like 40 of those moments every day with your kid. That are that level of joy. Exactly. So it's like, the idea- I mean, and that's just- that's not spinning it, that is just the truth.
Yeah. You know? I was like, Lee looked at me the other day and it was like, this is kind of crude sometimes. She's like, you know, after she goes to the toilet, she sits there waiting for me to wipe her butt. And it's like, I'm watching this kid and she's like, okay, daddy. And I'm just like, this is the greatest moment of my life right now. This is the fucking- this is the best moment of my life right now.
I mean, it's just crazy. Scotty and I were walking down the street in Chicago and we saw this one woman carrying like maybe a five-year-old kid in her hands. So he's kind of a big kid and her- and his shoe fell off and she was pissed. She was walking like 50 miles an hour. And then 20 steps behind was the husband with two other kids in there. Everybody's screaming and crying. And I turned to Scotty and I go, we both looked at each other, we're like, thank God.
Fuck that. Weed. I have to say that is not my experience, you know? Not only is that not my experience, the other thing that's not- people keep saying it flies by and I'm like, I guess so. I have not experienced that. I feel like I have changed 20,000 diapers. It's like Groundhog Day.
It's like things couldn't progress more, you know, faster. That's hysterical. Yeah. There's fast parts and slow parts, but the reason I asked that question earlier is I did find for me that one of the things it does too is it accelerates your work on yourself because you want to not infect them with the crap you don't have yet figured out. Yes. 100%.
Yeah. Yeah. Of course. There's that saying that this guy knows. He says like, I don't want my kids to have to recover from their childhood. Yeah. Oh, I love that. Recover from your childhood.
Yeah. Or from mine, but certainly from theirs and, you know- Sorry to interrupt. Just real quick on that self-esteem thing. I do think a key element that I've discovered is I found myself saying, telling me and myself and others a narrative about certain things, my childhood, my relationship to my parents, like this thing, press play. I'm a kid from Philly.
I got a chip in my shoulder. It's like, I'm always going to look up. It's whatever it is. And eventually you're like, actually, what is the truth? Right. Like, what was my childhood? And the minute I actually had a real assessment of my childhood, my upbringing, then I had a foundation to work off of, without the foundation, it is, I think, impossible, literally impossible
to build self-esteem because you're building on something that's fabricated. Because you chose not to acknowledge your childhood? You didn't remember it? Or why? No, I remembered it. It was shaped by whatever insecurity or however I learned how to survive, I thought, in this world, I created a narrative that allowed me to survive in the way that I could. But the older you get, the more narrow that your life becomes because you're not really
living your true life because it's not even based on reality. And it's really popular to keep telling a story. Whatever story you're telling about yourself is a way that your life is going to go. What you've got to do is start to change the story. It's like, there's this idea that anytime you take a memory out and look at it, you change it every time and you put it back and you change it. So whatever you have happening now, Sean, it kind of goes to what you're saying. If you're not feeling good about yourself and then you take that memory out, you affect
it. And you go, well, this is what happened. Well, that's actually kind of what you're saying, Billy. That's not what happened. And what you're doing is you've been telling yourself this fucked up story and it starts to get worse. So the gap between what happened and what actually happened and what is, that gap gets wider and wider and there's more and more pain in there when you do that.
Stolen election. Mm. Anyway. You won't stop. Sean, Jesus, we're not going to check the fucking voting machines again. Sean, real quick, January 6th, where were you? Real quick. We'll be right back.
And now back to the show. Well I wanted to ask a question about an hour ago about your career, but I've never asked you. I can't believe I never asked you. I'm sure you got this in the press junket and everything, but I don't know the answer. Why did you pick a star is born to Jason's point way, way earlier when it was done, I don't know, two, three times before and weren't you scared to take on such a massive iconic kind of thing?
It's hard to ask such a dumb question. Because it does put a target on, I mean, it takes a lot of guts, dude. Yeah, and I know you've been asked that, I'm sure, a million times, but I've never asked you that. Well, I mean, as Jason knows, you can't really choose what it is is going to motivate you to do all that work that it fucking takes to write and direct something. And it's just sort of, you know, I always deep down thought maybe I could like play a rock star only because I thought I could crush air guitar, you know, as Will knows.
So much so, but I'm so crazy about like making sure that I went on Jimmy Fallon and I asked, I said, can I do an air guitar just to see if I believed it? Right. I'm not kidding. So I went on, I went on the tonight show and I said, can I do down by the river by Neil Young? And I did it and I looked at it and I was like, I think I buy that. Okay.
I'll do a star is born. That's hysterical. That's fucking hysterical. I'm like, I think I could pull this off. I wasn't sure before, but I think maybe I'm going to use the tonight show. It was a workshop. Have you seen our net do air base? Oh God.
Yeah. Are you kidding? Night court. Come on. And then he goes right into law and order. Law and order. Law and order. I was, no, but you did night court too.
Didn't you? I've done, I've done night court. You know, the best one of the best air guitarists of all time is John Glazer. But we, I went, yeah, we did air guitar with Conan and I threw him the flute in the Law and Order team song and then Conan started doing the fucking, no, the clarinet. The air clarinet. So you had to wet the reed, wet the reed, wet the reed. So now I have another thing.
So a star is born and then Leonard Bernstein, what is the music thing? What, when did the music love stars? So the truth is, the stars born, I wanted, I wanted to tell a love story. I always thought like that seemed moving to me. That's what I, and then I thought, well, there's no better way as you know, Sean, is like, you can't hide when you sing. I mean, you literally cannot hide. It's impossible because your voice is the instrument and it has to be loose for the
chords to vibrate. And if you're tense or you're stuck, it's not going to work. So I thought, gosh, if I could like marry that in a way, that would be, that would be awesome. And so that's how that sort of started and got it. That was a property that was around Warner Brothers and Clint East was going to do it and he asked me, but I didn't think I could play Jackson Maine. I hadn't done American Sniper yet.
I hadn't done Elephant Man and I thought, I honestly thought that I couldn't, I would be acting. Like I was like, I just don't know enough honestly about life and shit. I don't think I could play this guy. And then once I thought I could play it, he didn't want to do it. And then I thought, well, you know what, I am 40. All the directors I admire, they don't really want me to do their movies. So what am I going to do?
And I, and I, all I want to do is be at the center of the creative experience. I'm going to have to fucking do it myself. I've spent a decade. Wait a second. When you say that, no, the directors you admire want you to do their movies. I mean, it's just the truth. Look, I had, in no way, look, I've had an incredible opportunity to work with great directors. But, you know, like the Cohen brothers, Martin Scorsese, Paul Thomas Sanders, David Fincher,
you know, the list goes on and on. We, I just couldn't, you know, be in any of those guys movies. Catherine Bigelow. So, so, and I was 40 and I was like, I just spent a decade on the road, basically, and had like, you know, two or three experiences where, you know, it took, it took like a pound of flesh out of me because I am so invested in the projects I do. And I felt like I wasn't working with people that I really wanted to work with to grow and get better.
And it was like, I'm 40, I want a kid, I want to slow down, and I want to do stuff that I really care about. And that's what started that. So, so, so now that you're doing Leonard Bernstein. And that was another thing. I always wanted to be a conductor, honestly. Like, since I was a kid, Bugs Bunny, Tom and Jerry, you know, and then spending hundreds of hours by myself as a kid pretending I could conduct like air guitar.
And then this project was around. I just finished a Star Wars board and I thought, gosh, let me research Leonard Bernstein. If I feel like there's a story in there that I could commit four and a half years to because I don't know how to do it any without any with a shorter time. Can I write it and do it? And then that's how that started. And I, and I just did all this research about this incredible family, the Bernstein's and Felicia Montalegre, his wife, fascinating, their relationship, fascinating the kids.
And I thought, and how they're articulate, they are about about their feelings. There's the movie, a movie about marriage, a movie about family. That's it. It's nuclear because it's this fucking music that is just, you know, music is nuclear. I had a secret weapon in a Star Wars board and it was Lady Gaga. The secret weapon I have in this movie is fucking Leonard Bernstein and Gustav Mahler. That music. And, and, but, but what is the, what is your connection with music?
Like, did you? I don't remember you singing Bradley before Star Wars. I never sang. No, no. Yeah. So when you were like singing the thing, I'm like, wait, Bradley's singing all these songs. But I will.
I worked my ass off. I know. Obviously. I mean. You know, I had to work really hard because we did everything live. We sang everything live. Dude, it was, it's incredible that you did it. It's fucking nuts.
It's, it's fucking crazy. Yeah. Look at Jason. Jason couldn't do anything. No, no. If you ask them right now. I can't even do my hair. Jason, do something.
He's a gorgeous man in the world. Look at him. He's so gorgeous. Look at him snap. Both hands. Both hands. Same time. And talk, and talk.
What about, where does the, you know, this is kind of a trite question. I'm sure you've answered this one a bunch of times too, but the passion between acting and directing, they're completely different in their creative agendas, endeavors and goals. One is a bit more singular and, and the other one is a bit more sort of global with multiple departments and you're, you're anyway, where do those two things balance for you and sit, you know, I'm not going to say which do you like more, but what, what, what type of mood are you in when you gravitate more towards one versus the other? The truth is it's always been the same thing.
It's never been different. Whether it was being on alias and asking for everybody's dailies on VHS tapes that I would watch at home and sit in the editing room every time I wasn't on set. Cause I really, all I did was like do three scenes and ask Sidney Bristol like how her trip was and like make popcorn. So I didn't, it wasn't doing anything. And, and, but I learned like this was fascinated about the process of making cinema and, and it's always been that.
And so it's never really changed. And I don't even see it as two separate things, Jason, it's, it's all part of the same thing. But the answer is there's nothing I enjoy more artistically than, than doing the things that, that you and I've talked about a lot, which is, you know, having an idea, exploring it, writing it, um, and then asking a group of people that you admire and inspire you to come help you do it and create it and then put it out in the world. It's greatest, it's the greatest gift ever. It's great.
If there's nothing better, there's just nothing better. Yeah. I love that. That's our first commercial break. Well now a word from our sponsors. Yeah. I was just going to say, let's go from that to, I think you told us. Bradley, I was just thinking, he's talking about the 10 years of being on the road.
And I was thinking about, uh, the hangover movies. I mean, you, you went and you did like, we're not even mentioning the fact that you were in three of the, the, the top grossing. Can I show you this real quick? Can I show you guys this real quick? So I haven't talked to NZZAC together in years and my daughter woke up this morning if I play this kind of play. So this is my daughter this morning.
So I texted those guys and I was like, hangover for, let's do it. Because remember who let the dogs out? That's like the thing of us walking down the hall. Dude, that's amazing. Did you get that from watching the movie or what? How did she know? Yeah, I show it to her. We watch it every Friday.
Yeah. She's four years old. Yeah. Way to go, Shanya. She's watching, she's watching a hangover already. You know what? I'm glad you didn't have kids. I'm glad you didn't have kids.
And now I get why your father left too. Listen. Oh Jesus. We're going to get real. Humor. Here's the thing about mean humor. Humor is a thing. Somebody at, somebody at Franny's school, I guess said to her that they liked horrible
bosses or something. So she says you wanted to watch it. So I started watching with, with Franny the other night and my 10 year old. So Franny's 15, Maple's 10. And we're five seconds into the movie and, and Aniston is talking about breaking her finger, fingering herself to Penn Badgley, watching Steve W. She's like, whoa, whoa, I totally forgot how inappropriate it was. And it's just like, you got to be careful.
You got to be careful. I know. I'm not very good at that. I have to say. If you ask my daughter like a white lotus, she'll go, the guy who pooped in the suitcase. But she is not yet watching Hangover, right? Bradley, when you're knees, knees deep in a, in a, in a movie like this, that you're working on.
Oh, good. In a movie. No, it just, that could have gone either any, any direction. Do you, are you, do you have any kind of other project that you can think about or any kind of thing that you're thinking beyond that? Are you all in 24 hours a day on this one thing? And I can't imagine you can focus on it. I think every experience is different, but I will say this.
The last month, I have not been sleeping. I really have not been able to sleep. I keep playing the movie in my head and, and I have like acid reflex, which I've never had. I've like, you know, pepsidacy by the bedside. Now Lenny, Lenny couldn't, Lenny was an insomniac. And there's actually a scene in the movie where, where, where Julia Vega, who was there with them for the whole life, like wipes the thumbs off his face.
I don't know what's happening. But this one, I have to say, has me pretty possessed. Oh, wow. Do you have time to do anything stupid on the weekends or late at night? Is that, and then being a dad is literally that. Yeah. Yeah. And Leah's mother is incredible.
And, but we share custody. But when I have her, you know, it's just me and Leah and, and thank God, here's another thing about being sober and having humility is like, I realized I can't do this movie and take care of it without any help. So literally tonight in like minutes away, someone is coming that's going to stay in New York and help, help out till the end of the shoot, which I never would have done. But I'm thank goodness I'm doing it. I know, which is amazing.
You've never done. You're an incredible dad in that way. Jason said it before, but we all, we've all gotten to witness it and you're in. But only selfishly because of those things about the 40 moments of like life, you know, life moment. I just love it. I just, I don't want any moment that I could be with or not to be with her. Yeah.
Yeah. For sure. That's why I like later she'd be like, dad, and you never were apart. You were so, you, you stuck to me all the time. No, but I thought it was a good thing. I know. It's why I'm fucked up dad. That connection.
No, that connection. Much love. Jason, your kid's name is quick. Three, two, one. Yeah. Genny. This is what I'm talking about. No, you guys are both great dads and, and yeah, you're right.
You don't want to, and it's not even that you don't want your kids to say that later is you just don't want to not do it now. You don't want to miss it. And you want to. I just enjoy it. It's really so. I just enjoy hanging with her. I just love it.
Yeah. Yeah. Do you want to picture the elephant man behind you? Yeah. There he is. Yes. You, you in that play was one of the best performances I've ever seen in my whole life. Oh man.
Yeah. Thank you. At the Booth Theater, right? Yes. We're originated. Yeah. So crazy. I'm so sick that I didn't see that.
It was so good. Yeah. And you know what I noticed? Bradley, every single night, correct me if I'm wrong, but what I noticed is you're wrong. Oh, you mean about this story? Okay. You had as, as your performance as the elephant man on your hand, you had a rubber band around
your hand, right? No, no, no. I did this thing that I used to do as a kid, you know, that I'm sure you guys did, you know, this thing. Oh, you did that? And you just held it there the whole time? Fold the fingers over each other. Yeah.
So I thought you had a rubber band around your hand? No. But didn't you? I don't think, I don't remember you telling me that your back was all fucked up. Oh yeah, man. Not only that, the left side of my face got larger than the right and my right hand, because we did 365 performances and my right hand actually started to like have issues. Yeah.
So when, have you done theater since then? I have not, unfortunately. And I, yeah, which sucks, because I do, it's, it's one of those things where it's the hardest thing, it's the most rewarding and it's the most monotonous thing. It's like it's all these things, right? And time consuming, too, right? Yeah. But the monotony of it, and you're like, oh my God.
And then you're like, oh, it's kind of great. Oh, Jesus. Oh, I kind of love it. I'm, I hope to do it right after Maestro, actually. Maybe Williamstown, because then it's a five week thing, bam, you're in and out. Ooh. Yeah, that'd be good. I remember seeing that.
I mean, it's the greatest thing in the world. Dude, what was the one you did before that, three days ago? I mean, even, what did you think of the tour? I mean, the energy of the tour, though, right? When you guys were there. I mean, I love it. I was sick. There's nothing like it.
There's just fucking, there's nothing like it. I was sick. How funny though, Will, you're like, I got this crazy idea. We're all talking about it, about doing this thing. Man, I think it sounds great. Well, cut to. Oh my God. This is the 100th episode.
What? Yeah. What the fuck? It's really ridiculous. It's crazy thing we're going to do it this time, either way, we couldn't have had the more perfect 100th guest. Oh, man. Really? It's perfection.
It makes sense because we're all family. About 50 times I've forgotten that we're doing the podcast right now. Me too. I fucking totally forgot. I know. You know? It's so nice. Yeah, Bradley, man, I'm so glad that you're on this 100th episode with us.
You're such a big part of all of our lives. I love you, man. And just keep fucking doing it. Keep reaching. I don't think I'd ever say this earnestly to anybody, but keep fucking reaching for, you know, the stars and hitting for outside of the park and taking big swings. It's fucking awesome and inspiring and just love you, dude. Love you, Bradley.
I love you guys. Really? It really is. It's very exciting to watch you go. Oh, man. Thank you. And we wish you were here tonight. I know.
I was listening and I thought, oh, fuck, I wish I was there, man. When does the movie come out ish? Jason will give a toast in your name. Please. Yeah. It won't come out till the fall of 23. I think. Okay.
Holy shit. You're shooting the whole thing out in New York? No. No. We started in Massachusetts. Then we're in New York, East Hampton. And then we take a break and then we go to Italy for three weeks and then we end in London. And the last day, the last two days are Mahler's Resurrection at Ely Cathedral.
If you know that, like it's one of the largest Gothic cathedrals in the world, live conducting it with 180-core, 74 orchestra, the soprano, mezzo-soprano, we just cast these incredible singers. I mean, it's going to be, I can't even like... Bradley, I'm so friggin excited. Jesus. Who knows if it'll work? You know, because we're going to do it live. Like it's like it either works or doesn't.
Just taking on the scope and the scale and just the logistics of it alone, you know? It sounds impressive. I just couldn't admire you more. No, it's amazing. And just to have that kind of, that ambition, speaking of it, Jason did, you know, he's going to tee off tomorrow and he's going to play 18 and then he's going to do a six-mile run on a treadmill. I mean, that's ambition too.
And I might hit a half bucket of balls after. I mean, that's ambition as well. It's a lot. And Sean... You never played golf back in the day, right? This is relatively new, right, Jason? Well, no, I started when I was 18, but then I stopped for a long time. Oh, you did?
Wow, I felt like when we first met, you were not like Will was obsessed with golf and you didn't play. Is that not true? I think I had stopped for a while. Then Will got me back in during COVID. By the way, real quick, the best thing in this, I think in the smartest thing is that like, who was the guest? And he's like, Jason, didn't you win that like Formula One race?
And you're like, yeah, yeah, I did. Like what? No, he's one of the... It was a cheesy celebrity race. Talk about the sassan guy who can do anything. No, but it's Jason, please. It's like, it's like just admit your power. So it's true.
It's like, dude, he fucking won a Formula One race. It wasn't Formula One. Badly, Badly, not only didn't do that, it was the Long Beach Grand Prix thing and he did that. And then recently he goes... You won the whole thing. No, he won. And then recently we're talking about a golf tournament.
We're talking about a different golf tournament. The Bob Hope River, he goes, yeah, I won that twice out of this one. What do you mean you won it? What are you talking about, dude? I know. What are you talking about? This is Bradley's time. It's really true.
Sean, Sean got... Here we come. Right, you got the best customer ever at Shaky's Pizza. Whatever it was. Right? A million miler, they said. A million miles of pizza. You ate a million miles of pizza.
Just impressive. That's it. Oh, man. Bradley, you get fired and get out of here and come hang out. Come on. All right. That's enough already. You have to fire himself.
Bradley, thank you, man. Bradley, thank you, everybody. Love you, pal. Love you, buddy. Guys, thank you, buddy. Thank you for this. Love you. What an honor.
Thank you. Love you. Love you. Love you. Love you. Love you, buddy. Great. Perfect guest for 100 episodes.
And like I said at the end, he feels like family. So it was a perfect idea. I know. I know. That's what I thought. We need to have somebody that we all know and that there's history and family that we had on. And of course it was wild that we hadn't had Bradley.
We had him on the tour, but, you know. And just so generous to be so honest and open with knowing that it ain't just us three, you know, kicking around and having old times. But I love chit chats like that because how many people that helps, how many people relate to it. If you're having similar issues that you can relate to somebody even like Bradley Cooper, who's going through the same thing as anybody else. So it normalizes it.
That's a constant process. But it's the ability to actually connect with yourself and be able to go and Bradley has, and I mean, and you guys have noticed it too. We talked about, you know, he has done a lot of work and he's, you know, and we know other people have too in our lives and we have members of our family and ourselves who we talk about these things all the time about being in touch with where we're at and what's going on and being honest with yourself and what's great is Bradley. Self-aware.
Yeah. And that self-awareness comes from being honest about where you're at. And, you know, I think that I love that stuff. I can talk all day about the, you know, the idea of whatever it is you are, whatever story it is you decide to tell about yourself. Fucking people love getting hung up on their story. They love it. They love it.
They love it. It's the whole idea and they go, and also like that goes for the future too. If you're talking about, well, you know, shit's going to be really hard. And it's all you can decide. And for more information, check out my Instagram stories. Yeah. Sorry. I forgot to keep driving people to your socials.
If you want to see Sean and Scotty high in their living room dancing to commercials. Look, that's the story we tell ourselves. That's the story we're telling. Sean and Scotty on a gummy. The way we did last night. But truly this, this 100 thing is a real, a real, like I'm surprised every time I, that we have a podcast. Like, I'm like, Oh, this podcast tomorrow.
Like, I can't believe we do a podcast. I can't do that. I hope I never get used to it. Because it stays as soon as it's like, Oh yeah, that's so great. We get to go do that. So thank you everybody for letting us do this. Like, not only do we get to connect with our friends like Bradley, but we get to meet new people that we don't know.
And we get to kind of pick their brain. And hopefully we're asking some of the questions you want asked. And you keep listening. We'll keep doing it. Yes. It means just the world to us. So thank you. Thank you for listening.
Thank you for being there. And I'm so grateful that you give us the opportunity to do it. So thank you. A big genuine sincere. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. And I'll see you next time.
The tallest, most bold capital letters of. Bye. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.